so that's a entrance height commands on
your stream and I don't see it and I
it's up to you I really don't care both
is fine okay it does feel learning it's
all good okay I think it should be
working now
yeah so I don't have that many events I
only have mineral deposit I'm feeling
like helium probably
uh interesting so I will what's your
second chord choice
it's um the interplanetary cinematics
okay both are good corpse it will depend
on your starting end
yeah I don't have that much
yeah it should be helium unless you have
great buildings tags here
yeah this is an easy alien for me yeah
seems like
it's a decent hand
s you can keep this noctis is always a
keeping starting can knock this city
[Music]
yeah why though why do you guys like
this city and not other cities it's
insane because
it has a reserved spot yeah and uh
usually a lot of Greenways are coming
down in the west especially when you're
ecoline so if your opponent is ecoline
you can usually get a five-point noctis
during the game or uh and uh it's a it
is um it gives us two plants it gives uh
two rebates it's just a very good card
and it's it's uh it's worth keeping
on the other Maps it's less interesting
obviously but on this one it's just it's
just good it's always a key uh what is
what are your first five cards
you can keep noctis farming as well
so this Mining rights and noctis large
Convoy mineral deposits is probably all
I'm keeping yep feels good
it's interesting uh am I playing noctis
anytime soon no I don't think so so the
energy production from Martian
Industries is not that huge right well
biosphere is a bad balloon but uh here
you seem to have a rush set up right
yeah
you will have four hit products from the
get-go you need plans to supplement that
I personally would go buy a sphere but
if you want to go biolab that's actually
not terrible Martian Industries is the
one I would not take in this situation
it's very interesting you guys want to
keep lock the city without energy
production
all right
yeah because it's a it's the last gen
play usually not the city is the last
gen place so you have plenty of time to
find energy and it's pretty much a card
that is almost always worth it unless
the opponent goes a long way to uh to
put uh
random tiles that are not greeneries
next to noctis
[Music]
all right so like this looks good yeah I
think that's decent
yeah that is true actually AAA wouldn't
be that bad
AAA is a arrow-break ammonia asteroid
that is would you consider this
three hit prod and one punch
it's not horrible when you know you have
to rush uh here it would probably be
worth it yeah
I never thought this capital
it is playable sometimes not often but
sometimes it is
would you play gen 1 power plant
carbonate in adapt and lichen
yeah
definitely the answer is yes then yeah
[Music]
I have a play here I can do
um
can I do standard project mineral
deposit Mining rights I wanted this 14
19 100 projects what signup project do
you want to do Greenery
no I'm thinking standard project
asteroid to get the heat pump and then I
can set Mining rights it's not worth it
the heat will be will be flying anyways
because I have heat production myself
well it you haven't seen what I will
play next but uh I assure you it will be
playing and so what you want to do is
definitely not SP asteroids in this case
it's too secure ground whoever wins the
ground wins the game here
so you don't want to spend your precious
cash on SP asteroids especially
so the question is where I put the
Mining rights then are thinking here at
the uh usually best choice is
obviously it's usually the best choice
unless you have absolutely no titanium
and uh
a lot of Steel plates
yeah would have skipped the crap out of
a general
um I'm not feeling the a either but
uh I'll probably pass here
I don't know what crap he's talking
about though because you didn't keep
that many cards and the card you get
were good oh [\h__\h] he said he would have
skipped the crap to play a oh
interesting
really interested you would have skipped
knocked this
uh
oh
wow
gen one
hey I I have never
even could imagine this is a thing you
would do interesting holy [\h__\h] I have a
I have a big decision here and just like
I'm leaning towards Card War
but uh
I probably need to go
Plantation
for you do you have do you have science
types played already
uh
everything looks bad to be honest but I
think Plantation is slightly better than
artificial Lake will certainly be
playable that's for sure in this game
but uh yeah the problem is that you have
no tag for Plantation it it will
probably be good but uh you cannot be
certain it will artificial Lake will
always get value but it's usually pretty
marginal Plantation could be good I
think I would take Temptation in your
shoes and hope that you find science
facts yeah interesting which card would
you take here I I think I will take uh
third one
uh
yep
yeah to enter anthracite I think uh I I
just thought AA was all was like way too
expensive for what it gives you I never
thought it was a good card
but interesting that he would go for it
well you're not answering my question
uh you said
yeah you're throwing some meth at me
no I'm asking if you would play power
plant carbonate and adapted like in our
gentleman
uh I think power plant Carbonite would
be a kind of weak play but uh I think
you're buying this that this is the same
cost as a why is this why is this a weak
play explain
it's too expensive though
why
come on you just you're just saying that
like happening it's just bad card I
don't understand
it doesn't feel that strong to me but I
guess I'm not valuing heat production
power plant seven hours for an energy
production yeah Power Plant is one of
the cheapest ways yeah okay
power plant no no no no no we've
centered project power it's it wouldn't
be horrible actually for carbonate
genuine but uh it wouldn't be exciting
but uh yeah with power plants I'm
talking about the card
pain 7 for an energy
paying nothing for carbonate pain 12 for
adapted like
this is 28 for a three he'd brought in
one plane prod and yet you say you can't
understand a
yep
I guess you have a point I just never
thought a would be a good cut
I thought it was too expensive for what
it gives you
in those Ultra Rush games where you know
you have to rush it is a good
hmm but still I like noctis and deposits
so yeah
so what about here by the way my time is
running I'm thinking restricted area but
is this too greedy do I need to go for
cloud seeding no no Cloud sitting is bad
uh Cloud settings could be marginally
good in this game but it is always
protective I mean you want to talk about
a car that's never worth playing it's
Cloud City
okay
hey hey it's good Cloud settings one of
the worst cards in the deck probably
it could be playable here if oceans were
if if we had three oceans here I would
like loud City in this game
I wouldn't
so I think I'm keeping Plantation here
just hoping I get some time Sticks
at least I mean I have one with a
restrictor
so I think large Convoy convert is
probably the best I got
no
restricted
I guess not Convoy converts a very weak
play
it's basically a standard in The
Greenery here
yeah
plus if you play large Convoy convert
then he just puts an ocean down and
takes the Four pocket you're really bad
yeah if you play a large convoic convert
here I will cut you off from the
promotion walking North
which is uh which is really bad uh and
uh also you want to develop your card
row as fast as possible to try to
outscale Eco lines because uh I'm a
threat in the short game
love it and you're building towards a
short game so you want to give yourself
chances to find out
either card or one plant in a standard
e-spot
yeah I'm thinking God because my hand is
so unplayable right now
I kind of like the e-spot versus those
are fine both are fine
like yep the normal Eastern City Spot
one plant in the east
yeah
all right
and that actually
is quite painful to me because I
intended to play research outposts there
right now so I will have to play it next
to noctis because
I don't know you have noctis but well I
I know you have noticed but even if I
didn't I would have played it there
[Music]
so I can either pass or I can speaking
of carbonyl processing this is the play
I thought you were talking about going
actually and actually I'm obvious played
this very hard anthracite should be
pulling his hair out I should have
claimed the spots next to your
restricted area
and kept uh kept a research Outpost as a
Teleport my mistake
yeah I like to comment comment and
convert next to restricting
uh me I would just passed
you don't wanna you won't want to do
this stand-up power plant and carbonate
processing no it's really bad yeah I
agree uh this is what I thought you were
saying uh before in the event it would
be good gen one if you were controlling
the heat track but right now pushing the
contract difference it's not really in
seven and eleven is huge yeah yeah and
playing a gen one versus gen two right
yeah I misunderstood your writing before
I thought this is what you meant
oh
[Music]
so
I could maybe just risk yeah I think it
looks okay right of course
I actually could play higher mining
Industries here he can as well but I
guess it's a very short game so it's
probably not this card is probably
definitely one of the worst cards this
will wield back to you
I'm leaning towards card for myself here
the passing card 2 could be dangerous
okay
well
so Mass converter or giant space mirror
both of them are not that useful but I
guess it's dangerous to give a mascara
what do you think I'm never going to
play math converter probably but I have
two science already I could play it
that's true but uh
GSM since he has just titanium floating
yeah
because you don't know he has a target
for it but
and then you take the power
I guess since I have nothing to do I
might as well play this
well I mean you're working your way
towards your first card now
um
the parents I would take one of the
Power Cards
just like this
one and two
no
[Music]
go ahead and draw
maybe slightly better than this maybe
both
develop giant space mirror and carbonite
all right
[Music]
so you wouldn't play this at all I guess
no
good play this
might as well
nope wouldn't pay
you wouldn't play anything you wouldn't
I wouldn't yeah I would pass as well if
I was if yeah if I was in your shoes you
have no interest to pay to to play
anything here not just farming
is not something you want to play unless
it gives you an instant conversion here
it just makes your plants vulnerable and
uh you want to try to find parts of the
bio combo before you play it cards like
viral enhancers decomposers ecozone yeah
but well first of all I have nitrogen
richest right I have to play some blend
tags and also I could convert but not to
city next turn if I wanted to
no like how with a noxus farming now and
then I get the some plant press the
ocean yeah not the city and the
conversion no no not this is extremely
weak play
right this is where yeah this is
terrible to play both both of these
cards are I mean the only reason you
would even think about not this Farm is
because you have NRA but there's so many
more synergies that you can find my key
goes on viral
Etc and there's no you're not very
unlikely to want to convert by picking
up a plant on the board at the beginning
of the next gen so you're just gonna
float seven plants as well
um this I don't understand you cannot I
can 100 convert right if I do not
transforming and then knock to see it
comes in but Nocturne city is a terrible
play right you don't want to commit
yourself to making that play
okay
right this is the problem
it basically delays NRA by at least one
gen if you play that it costs you a
generation in production to play
nocticity
all right
so just pass here or do I hit no no I
would pass
[Music]
everything you organize around in Array
now right this is the card you want to
get down as quickly as possible so you
take protect your belly yeah but in that
case uh this plants I guess yeah all
right
nothing of this is good I think lunar
beams very weak I would take PhD
bacteria
especially since you passed a mess
intake still works I mean great that's
as irrelevant
huh
and so we take protective Ally yeah
that's probably all
um
yeah
I'm wondering here enter sites if you
were me would you pick Luna B
no
if it was gen 3 I would but here I think
it's a bit too late
and this is probably quite weak as well
I wouldn't bother
now I just draw
this is looking good for you boneless
because uh
um
I don't have much to do
yeah
I can protect the valley let's think
here so
what
I'm just thinking they have 41
51 56 cash
so you don't we can't quite get in right
down here
well but I can protect the value doctors
farming convert and then do this next
gen
I think I play protected Valley in the
middle of the board yeah right here yeah
yeah
but it's so weird to me this thing about
I thought it was very important for you
guys to protect your plants right now
I'm vulnerable to to plenty but if I
played this noctis farming last gen I
would be yeah yeah no I mean it worked
out the way that you were describing but
like
they're very this is basically the only
card that you would find that you'd want
to play that wouldn't give you a
conversion anyways all right
and if you like it's not really that
important to work around Plant hate
because you're always going to get hit
by it
no matter when you play it
huh
so I got my plant spent but I still play
should I just not play it and just play
it next yeah no no I may just pass again
all right
[Music]
over this
how many building taxes yeah
probably medical lab
but yeah this is pretty bad
this yeah
you just take the gas right
yeah not even bother with modeling
Expedition
no
doesn't really do anything
all right
yeah
looks good
[Music]
now we draw
is interesting
play not this Farm in
[Music]
yep
it's good
[Music]
I was thinking a brief circuit about the
medical lab and then going for Builder
but I'm sure that you wouldn't approve
let's look at the cards you would have
to play to get that yeah terrible
I mean I'm not gonna lie I would have
been tempted to play industrial microbes
early in the game but
I am for sure underestimating how fast
this game is going to be I it's probably
my issue
I mean
the most important thing is to get that
right down as quickly as possible so
we're really close to doing it last gen
it wouldn't have been close if you
played microbes
yeah
this is also my second Science Tech for
the plantation everyone
yeah that's true
[Music]
oh yeah I still have sorry if I rolled
here
I mean Theory a good standard project
Foundation if I want to
I know I can actually play this
I don't think there's a purpose
well hang on
yeah that's that's a way where I can
work towards the yeah now I think I
would just take the bonus ocean
wow you can take the bonus ocean well
not right now right I have to wait until
next time but no
yeah what am I missing no I mean
I would just take
[Music]
probably sell microbes yep
a big asteroid
oh yeah you have 24 heat I missed it
it's okay so microbes and take it
yeah
no no no no no because then he can take
the heat gun
just take the take one heat pump
[Music]
and pass
okay so you don't mean I can get it now
but instead of the Next Generation I can
get there is that what you mean yeah
exactly okay
let's go choose
all of this looks
[Music]
so I just passed
well here's the question is do we want
to play against right or not probably
I think so at this style yeah I mean I
could at the start of the next gen I can
burn a lot of his plants either way so I
think we pass yeah
I think you got this
unless I have crazy draws I'm not going
to win it
[Music]
no no no no that's done yeah I think
contact
uh or how many science tanks does he
have
I just checked I don't think either of
us have any yes I have to I have to left
one I also have two with this
so do I think I take I'll take
anti-graft yeah
all right that's actually
also hi boros
um
is not doing that much here
is there before us
go check over us
we have a lot of plant production so it
makes sense to me
yeah I mean it's close
yeah I mean I think our voice is better
so I don't think I keep anti-gravity
but the question is do I keep wave power
no but I would take herbivores and
Mars here here
oh he gave this back to me holy hell
Marseille Force pick what game are we
playing yes I thought it would be
impossible
no
I had a big asteroid people
[Music]
it was like plants or two cards I think
I'll take that plant no two plants next
to uh not uh not that one but the one
next to your protective Valley yeah that
one
but yeah
[Music]
oh hang on hang on let's see let's just
think here yes uh first of all there is
an argument to be made that I take the
heat bonus so he doesn't get it at the
start of the next gen but I'm not sure
no no no no no the only thing that
matters right now is terraformer
well there will be another reason to do
my thing like two plants two bushions
two of those just look at your hand real
quick look at your hand I only need
three points together
yeah I know I'm just you want to think
about the right sequence here
I think you go uh Plan conversion on two
plants and heat them
yeah so he doesn't get the bonus right
um
think about your cashier so
yeah playing conversion on two plants
and two cash
yeah maybe yeah
I mean I go to the left of his
tile
yeah I'm just thinking out loud here
um if I convert now immediately I can
take the last bomb and then
uh you're afraid he's gonna take no no
no no no you you can't take both heat
pumps because then you can't afford a
fun terraformer no but you need to it's
just the the order of which you do
things it's a little bit safer for my
plants to use them immediately but I
guess if you haven't no it's not because
then then you won't get terraformer
because he just SPS two asteroids and
you can't get terraformer
hmm
yep let's see
so you convert I would convert to the
left no on Southeast of no no no you
need two plants and it's got a bait to
the left of his tile
you see the only one he can get to
two plants to cash
here right next to yeah exactly oh [\h__\h]
he has a oh I didn't see this though
okay yeah that makes sense
and then hit them
[Music]
hmm I'm very important to get that
sequence proper because if you don't do
it properly then he can SP2 asteroids
and suddenly you can't get one TR
anymore
yep and now I'm screwed
[Music]
and now you convert your plants and you
find terraformer
yep you're right
so here on top of the yes yeah I like
that I'm not sure I can see my mouse
when I do this
uh no reason not to take it now yep
found it
[Music]
oh but now my point from earlier is
still here I can I can actually just
take the last heat pump if he doesn't
take it so he doesn't get it at the
start of next gen
yeah exactly which is worse
I mean either way he's probably not
gonna
[Music]
you're right
I think yeah
we'll take it
[Music]
huh
probably build the rest next one to be
taken
[Music]
and pass
very interesting game
yeah I mean I I think I know you guys
and you keep surprising me
keep knock the silly starting hand but
don't play it until last generation
that's the best thing about long destiny
is early in the game yeah I hate this
draft so much real point but at the same
time I thought Tempo was very important
in these short games so I don't know
I guess
I'm confused because what does noctis
have to do with Tempo plainness
that's all I mean I spend three goals
for the pattern in my opening hand
it seems the card has to be really good
if I just pick up this card in my
opening hand to play it in the last
generation especially when it's the
tempo game that's just I mean I think
it's like basically always four to five
points right
enter site look at my draft what would
you pick
can you play ecosystems
no I like a micro attack
does he have a micro time
he doesn't he doesn't have an animal
either
hmm
so I'm actually leaning towards research
here because I cannot let him have it
I think it's not unreasonable
to take research yeah
yeah that's what I would do I think but
uh yeah I think I'll take small animals
yep
I am considering Advanced LS but I I
think small animals is also better
Isis dead
let's look at our hands real quick
yeah I mean It's Tricky
it's unlikely that ecosystems is
playable for either of Youth because
it's very hard to get a playable micro
attack here
um
maybe just business contacts oh it's not
too too greedy
spend so many on just cuts
it's one of those two for sure
it depends on what he finds I mean 10 is
a lot to pay for cards at this juncture
yep
um
you could gamble on ecosystems
and keep it
yeah I'm having I have some card draw
lift in my hand it could be yeah
it's close but I think I'd lean towards
ecosystems
we can try
yeah
I think ecosystems is the pick for you
because I'm closer to it than you are
and uh yeah
yeah he already has fish so
huh I'll take Optimum and solar power is
useless
[Music]
is still worth it just for this I only
have one space event I want to play
probably not
um I mean I spent 10 I get six pack so
it's not terrible if I pick up one more
it's worth it but I don't know yeah
and for Sight would you pick up research
here or not
you can yeah you have a lot of cash and
yes yeah this feels so committal
if I only find dead cards this is
yeah this will be really hard to recover
from
I think you can take the first three
since you have Mars you
all right
so water is the last one to be
terraformed this game it looks like
maybe exactly yeah
those are some reps
what
I don't think I'm in rush I can just
draw right
now now I'd probably play Mars you
cycle power plan
[Music]
uh did cut I just draw again
yeah play standard attack or yeah draw
yeah draw using restricted
thank you
um
let's look at our hand
standard Tech draw and then I'm probably
looking at small animals herbivore or
something like this
yeah now I like uh little animals
[Music]
that's probably all we're getting
listen
here enter slightly to take plants or
fish
I think it's pretty close between the
two it's pretty close
both are pretty good
[Music]
what
quite a nice difference
I just uh get an animal
um
I think I would uh oh I have I can
actually play Plantation at home
and the challenges you give up in her
bit more if you do that but you do get
the four cash back
foreign
I have to convert at the start of next
gen either way yeah yeah so you can just
play Plantation there yeah
and the next gen I can start tip Ross
convert again
[Music]
now let's look at our hands
I think press probably
um
just flip through the Milestones again
it's not updatable yeah yeah
that's yeah I think we passed
[Music]
all
of the awards are surprisingly bad for
us
but I guess yeah I think I like his his
position quite a bit more
huh
standard City
[Music]
yeah I was thinking here you might do
that
it's a little bit I think I think it's
got you
it looks like it
so see you oh my God there's some cheap
phones at this point
I don't think it's catapult I played it
was it earlier today well I was told it
was probably a mistake because I'm so
late in the game the same applies here
right yeah I think CEO is just better
card here yep
okay anthracite look at the draft again
I think this is a win-win for you right
yeah it is but I'm trying to consider
considering I just SP the city
I still think this is the weakest
probably but
I think you take eagles only a mango
bank right
I'm not sure
yeah
does anyone have halves
no
then I guess you have to take pets
yeah I think so as well
oh
hello
well uh I'm I'm feeling ecosone and just
pray to God I get a microbe at some
point what do you think
otherwise mangrove
Minecraft is three points he goes onto
two I think Mangrove is better for you
to be honest but uh I don't think it
matters though to be honest I think
you're
I think a toast here yeah both first his
first picked up friends too
but if I am so maybe I should take ego
soon to try to get lucky
yeah but
yeah I mean that's this is it doesn't
matter what you pick
it's really bad for you I could just hit
the complete button I'll be back in a
bit all right
[Music]
the question is also what's better for
Gillian
I think Mangrove is the better card of
the two I think
it should be more points than ecozone in
the end unless you get lucky and find a
microbe tag but uh you can get a microbe
tag by with Mangrove on two cards as
well so I think I think it convinced me
yeah it's very unlikely I'll get the
Microtech
[Music]
uh
so I'm thinking I'm just gonna herbivore
and convert
but I mean you already played virus so
maybe I'm not in a rush
not in a rush to do what
I'm just thinking out loud I think I'm
gonna do herbivores and then convert
yeah that's the plate
[Music]
yeah
you worked towards an actors you have it
oh yeah
yeah that's a good point I should have
converted here because then my next
conversion can be next to Lexus I see
what you're saying
[Music]
I'll probably get there anyway but yeah
I see a small mistake
no
giant you can still go across the top of
us
yeah I mean to be fair if I if I went
here uh with my city he would put the
ecoso next to a noctis yeah yeah exactly
so I think it's fine
I would have played ecos on there
if if I didn't know you had the doctors
so yeah that's where I was
yeah I like Mangrove on cards now
yeah
that's the difference between me and you
guys I would have taken this spot like
ages ago but I think if I'm
understanding you you probably want this
now because we're desperate and we're
behind am I right oh
[Music]
my God that's a nice card oh I regret
not keeping the uh
but what can you do I think we should
play it though
you think we should play it
yeah unlocks ecosystems
yeah but is this last gen
I guess I can draw first
sure
I'm not sure this is last gen yet
[Music]
now I think you play viral grass
rid of
the field yeah
[Music]
yeah
I think that this is like the depth
level for you
yep
that convertible obnoxious now
[Music]
take your small animal
s
[Music]
uh he's not ending so I just passed I
guess
but yeah yeah
[Music]
maybe I had to risk minor earlier I'm
not sure
seems like a good way to lose
it feels like I'm losing anyway not sure
yeah but you cannot find Miner when I
have Superior prod and you have exactly
two uh no three minerals over me yeah
you're right it's it's like suicide I
guess uh none of the awards I could
really fund none of it yeah no you
cannot find anything anything you fund
is this guaranteed loss yeah
we can't find anything
greenhouses yeah yeah definitely
well
you got dead planner
I just keep greenhouses I guess yeah
I wonder sight will you keep copyright
here for landlord reasons
I don't think I would either
[Music]
oh I misplayed
I misplayed pretty hard actually what
did you do
I should have SP Greenery Greenery
oh yeah instead of what I did show your
hands
goodbye
no yeah
free water can you get this
probably not unless he has cuts
[Music]
Media Group
might as well
but I kind of don't want to play CEOs if
I get another Legend I want to find what
can I find birds or something
unlike this is pretty rough for me here
you can still win this you still have a
shot at it that's how
it is because I cannot end I cannot end
yeah
I think one more Generations
18 points yeah it seems like it's even
like an uphill battle
because you also have predators and
stuff right
and fish
I don't know what he can do to come back
no I don't either
I'm just passing here which is pretty
sad still
[Music]
oh I'm just
I can just pass as well to be honest
this I wanna not play that again Media
Group
never getting any better in case you
find something that you want to play to
open
yeah
but there's no point in playing it now I
might as well wait yeah I think there is
because if you want to open with
in it you're always playing Media Group
and you might want to open with an event
and then pass
yeah
[Music]
Lord I guess yeah
I'm getting I'm getting uh none of these
tasty animals I want
I think it's
uh
I probably need to steal some sort of
maybe
it's desperation at this point
I'm honestly hesitating between two and
four here
I think I will take two
for you
so many Death Cards
yeah sure
I mean I could grieve one Greenery from
him in some scenario but
17 minutes it's the only planet I got
but it's very desperate I have uh I have
a little I have optimal vibration but um
uh is it worth it oh no I have cash for
three plants
don't love it yeah
[Music]
I think I would go uh
seven cards
I draw and then if you don't find
anything out of a large Convoy
yeah
find anything
foreign
probably on
dealer card
[Music]
there's also two plants here no
yeah
you did pass him uh flooding which he
took so you might want to block the
plants
What in
flooding really is how to play though
I guess it came in once he wants to end
right so
yeah fine take the animals you sure
plants of course of course
animals are two points and uh
one
yeah yeah
[Music]
you're probably correct but I don't know
it feels like maybe some desperation
then load or something
they do planes into landlord what
happened I think as soon as you find an
award he just steals it and you can't
win the game
it did have flooding holy oh
but flooding gives him nothing that's
basically just to close the game
which is exactly what I need I'm leading
yeah I'm not saying it's bad but it's
just interesting flooding like literally
gives you zero right now
I mean it just saves him a bunch of cash
and there's the ocean
that's true
all right
[Music]
there goes the minor
and Raiders Steel
yeah I thought about it but I have I
just spend all my titanium so there's no
way I I am honestly no no this is wrong
rated steel what
and play investment one
okay
[Music]
is it because you remember he has a
steel cutter why he steal I don't get it
so I'm also looking at a standard City
and just greeneries and that's it
okay
I think
you can take the small animal
and play CEOs on herbivores
yep
[Music]
foreign
by the way the CEO was a mistake wasn't
it because he hasn't used Predators yet
oh my bad
I thought you're already ahead but it
doesn't matter I mean I'm not sure
yeah yeah you're right yeah I thought he
had
so it would have made sense for him no
he didn't but I assumed he did because
he should have given he could have drawn
yeah I should have said any point in
there so I just assumed he did just sell
two cards
so we make the Grievous mistake of
assuming that Galion is a good player
yeah I assuming I'm playing well it's
certainly in the stage right you should
know better
what are you saying should I sell two
card
yeah well just sell one and then sell
one that way you show him that you took
two in action
it's less click to actually sell two
cards but I guess it's just to show that
I'm not slow playing Jesus Christ
otherwise it's hard to see yes I see
what you're saying
so many gentlemen's agreements but uh
one of one of the others in here said
that in the last generation it's fair
game to slow play if it's I mean in this
game it doesn't matter because I'm lost
no matter what but
earlier today when I was in our equal
point with the
with mihao
they will talk about it it's okay to
slow play because it was very crucial to
who's gonna win the game
a new uh
show the awards real quick
doesn't look good for me
um there's a way I do landlord I think
yeah I think I would fun I think I'd
find Landmark yeah
found landlord install one card
I'm selling the natural Preserve sure
foreign
I would have funded if you hadn't
um what were your scientists Banger no I
would have funded Banker I kept
insulation for it okay
that was a good question
but I mean I mean obviously we're lost
no matter what but maybe could you
really have stolen landlord if I funded
it while it was cheap like early in the
game
that's your question
yeah yeah now you can't but could you
have done it earlier if I had funded it
while it was cheaper than 20.
it's the question
uh uh yeah if you had funded it earlier
I would have done everything I could to
steal it
yeah which probably wouldn't have been
enough because uh I had no time in hand
but uh
and now I think you can SP City to North
of noctis and convert on the card
[Music]
SF Memorial
why not
[Music]
um you can 23 23 I have SF Memorial yeah
you can play SF
but do I have this and this and this and
two standard greeneries should we map it
out or just play
just look at uh
what's that what's the countdown then
look
something uh I win landlord that's no
question
I think guys have greenhouses Advanced
ecosystem no and one green oh you first
first you want to do greenhouses
ecosystems actually
yeah because my point is I might not
have for two greeneries yes spend your
heat first by the way what
it's just there's a bug in the game I
don't know if they fixed it or not but
they fixed it is fine now okay
really okay there used to be
hmm
um so I have 23 that I have 17 left no
wait that's a mess so then I think we SP
another city on two plants here and we
can play SF still so might as well play
SF first
so convert on this deal
into cashback
there's also this these two plants
actually no no we're gonna put a city
there yeah come right there
and then play as if
uh City yeah first play SF
because you can afford it and you're
always playing it
and now SP that City
yep yep yep
and play Lightning Harvest
[Music]
yeah yeah that's pretty much it
gg gg
very close and well quite close in the
end
pretty close actually I'm gonna end at
90 right
uh it depends on your or before count
yeah
yeah you should have had 91 because we
put their we put the
CEO on the wrong car
yeah 91 and 94. Fred's was what killed
you
the draft where he got uh probably got
you guys on ego Zone and preds was
yeah
it's it's very easy for me to just be uh
be a smart in in hindsight but I think
the play was to do ecosone right and
just because one was only one point in
the end so it wasn't worth it for me no
I think Mangrove is fine it was just a
bad draft for you where he got to he got
two very good cards and yeah Mangrove
got you viral and Lancers so in inside
it's completely correct to take Mangrove
right because if you don't play
mangroves then you don't get viral and
if you don't viral you don't play Advent
Pico so Mangrove is four points whereas
ecosystems is like two points for you
um yeah so Mangrove is the right pick
it's just that was just bad draft pack
for you because he got two good cards
and preds pretz was like five points
here or something
well close game I thought we were
completely out maybe earlier landlord
somewhere no you can't do landlord
because then he just takes it anything
new funds he just takes I'm just looking
for a way I could have won it I refused
to believe that it was lost no matter
what others you know what I mean
I don't think it was lost no matter what
all you had to do was not get hit by
preds without preds
[Music]
you find breads then then here's the end
oh what happened
did I mess up something how did he win
by five I thought the game was telling
me he was only a hit by a few points
no well my final conversion was three
points converted between cities
yeah 92 to 88 when he passed okay yeah
well did you Gigi boneless good game